[Music]
it's all about the first impression I
[Applause]
[Music]
have been waiting to get around to this
one for ages and finally when given the
option the folks over at the Council of
geeks patreon voted to do it so let's do
it let's rank the opening titles of
Doctor Who all of them classic right up
through the most recent one that
premiered with series 11 of the modern
era so we've actually got quite a few of
these things to get through more than
you would think because some doctors had
more than one version of the opening
credits so we've actually got 19 of
these get through less always any more
time starting at the bottom
[Applause]
[Music]
these seventh doctors opening titles
debuting with time and the Rani in 1987
now I'll start out by saying there's
actually no version of the opening
tunnels that has nothing to like there
are still some things like even here
some of the aspects of the arrangement
for the opening theme that is pretty
good I like how the timing of the
asteroids that fly away from the viewer
sort of really hit them the time with
dude you you in the opening theme that's
cool
but there's a couple of massive problems
with this one starting with the fact
that it is too long and it lingers on
the bit that in my mind only belongs in
the closing credits the doo dee doo doo
doo doo and it just has this CGI TARDIS
spinning it's very showy offi of these
cgi graphics that don't look great and I
don't I mean granted I wasn't watching
at the time but I don't think even for
the time look that good they looked kind
of sterile like a little novel but
that's about it
novelties about all it has going on for
it so between the CGI that isn't worth
what they're milking it for and the
theme just going on for too long with
the bit of it that I don't think has any
business being in the opening end of the
title of Doctor Who it should all be the
mysterious true element not the not the
more heroic middle bridge bit that
shouldn't be in there and on top of that
the doctors face will be coming back to
the doctor's face thing and my feelings
on that in general but first of all the
kind of silvery thing they've got look I
don't know if this is actually the case
but it looks like they actually painted
Sylvester McCoy silver it looks like
he's got like pancake makeup on and then
he winks and like no no it's like a
creepy like somebody called the police I
need an adult kind of wink and then of
course it caps off with the worst logo
that dr. who has had at some point I'm
sure I'll rank the logo separately but
like this thing's ugly next up the
Fourth Doctor with the second version of
the Fourth Doctor
opening credits so this was the one that
swapped out the sort of blue psychedelic
sort of time tunnel look for the star
field and there's a couple of things
about this that don't work for me very
well at all
let's start out with the fact that the
face the look the face that they chose
to use for putting the doctor's image up
there it looks awful
like what do they have to work with that
they looked in that said yeah that's the
image to use what oh god it's hideous
and then it zooms at the camera
oh man look we'll be coming up to this
later but prior to this when the doctors
face showed up its ooh it was came away
from the viewer having us having a zoom
at us I don't like that in general I
don't like it here I don't like it any
of the other times that we used and it
actually kind of became the standard
after this one which I hate but God just
that choice that face no wrong face okay
16 and 15 are going to be the sixth
doctor's opening credits at the
lower-ranking is going to be the one
from the trial of Time Lord and then his
original ones starting with the twin
dilemma goes above that they're visually
they're basically identical they're
they're just it's a little too rainbow
II in terms of like that's sort of a
prism effect it's decent up to a point
but like it's too colorful much like the
six doctors outfit in general and again
the face thing which I'm not loving in
general and the only reason that one is
ranked above the other is that it is a
slightly different version of the actual
theme and I think the one that they
updated for trial of a Time Lord is a
little bit softer doesn't hit as hard I
just don't like it as much there's kind
of a nice almost like sort of a ward
drum kind of feel to how hard though the
version from his first credits hits and
I miss it when it's gone but that's the
only difference
next up number fourteen third doctor his
original credits debuting with spearhead
from space and honestly the show is just
too enamored with the fact that it is
color and its garish and gaudy and ugly
and I don't like it much like how the
seventh doctor's opening credits is too
enamored with the fact that they can do
CGI that they just do it this is too
enamored with color and they just do it
it's just bathed in these just oh the
like the colors are just gross it's not
even like the rainbow thing of The Sixth
Doctor before it's just yeah and the
only reason this is above the others is
because the image for the face works a
little bit better for me here number 12
the second set of credits for the
eleventh Doctor's are a first one from
the modern era this debuted with the
snowmen and this it's not bad we're kind
of out of the ones that I have major
problems with but I am still gonna be
nitpicking a bit here there's a few
things that I don't love about this I
don't like sort of the camera whip
panning like through the the stars
there's also a little bit too much like
sound effects a little bit too many like
woosh POW like sound effects as things
whiz by and whatnot that doesn't really
add anything they brought the face back
after not having had the doctor's face
in the modern era
it's way subtler than it was in classic
era I'll give it that and that's
preferable I still don't really like it
being there and overall it's just kind
of okay next up number 12 fittingly
enough the opening credits for the 12th
doctor
and I wish I liked these better I really
do the gears I'm kind of okay with and
and like the version of the theme
it fits the more mechanical look of it
you know it feels like it it has like
that sort of mechanical cacoon cacoon
kind of going with it so like it matches
but I don't really love it all that much
just as a version of the composition and
there's something about when it spirals
into the face of the clock and like the
Roman numerals I think there's something
I don't like about that it's hard for me
to quantify and put my finger on it but
I guess in the same way that I don't
like it when the Time Lords are shown to
be just too close to human in there in
their culture and their behavior
um that like having the Roman numerals
just throws me off maybe it would have
worked better for me if it was like some
weird Gallifrey in numbers or something
but something about that it just doesn't
quite do it it's pretty original though
and I'll give it that that's why it's a
little bit higher than it might have
otherwise been it's a pretty unique
piece but I kind of wish we gotten a
crack at another one for Capelli other
than this one next up number eleven the
Eighth Doctor the credits used for the
opening title for the Doctor Who TV
movie of 1996 I really only have one
major issue with this but for me at
least it is a major issue and I
mentioned this back with the seventh
doctor's remember how what I considered
to be the more heroic part of the Doctor
Who main theme you know how I said that
shouldn't be in the front end you should
save that for the closing credits the
front end should be the more mysterious
stuff well I already mentioned how it
bugged me with the seventh doctor's
credits that that was in there at all
the eighth doctor's credits it opens
with that
[Music]
it doesn't even open with the dude you
how do you not open with that so this
whole thing's tainted by original sin
but truth be told once we're past that
and into the rest of it visually it's a
little bland
not a ton going on it's just kind of a
sense of the time vortex but I actually
really like the composition on this
thing after that original misstep like I
like it a lot if they just jumped that
from there opening this would have been
significantly higher because I really
like the composition and visually it
doesn't do anything wrong and the logos
even pretty decent number 10 the fifth
doctor's opening credits debuting with
Castro Velva in 1982 so this one again
we continue with the starfield thing
that like I said was already kicked off
with the Fourth Doctor previously the
face chosen not nearly as off-putting as
that one from the Fourth Doctor was but
I still don't really care for the whole
star field the stars come together and
then it says facing again I really do
not like the face coming at the viewer I
really really don't like that it's fine
it's a pretty good version of the theme
and like going for the star field in
general sort of taking it out of the
confines of the vortex it wasn't an
awful idea and if it wasn't for the face
zooming in it'd probably be a bit higher
than this but man I really hate that
number 9 also oddly fitting the 9th
doctor's credits starting with Rose in
2005 now you're gonna get it's kind of a
pretty tight confines of a lot of the
Davies era opening credits cuz there
wasn't a huge difference between them
but there are little tiny subtle
differences between them that causes
some to be ranked above others this one
is the lowest ranking of the Davies era
opening credits because I feel it's the
roughest the specific version of the
logo is the one I like the least they
tweaked it a little bit later on and
those other little touches that later
versions did that I liked over
this number eight the eleventh Doctor's
first opening credits starting with the
eleventh hour'
in 2010
[Applause]
I like the urgency of the composition on
the on the opening theme in this one I
do like that quite a bit and the logo is
pretty decent and there's nothing wrong
with the visualization of the time
vortex being more like almost like a
circle of clouds and there's lightning
and then it like there's a burst of fire
and it's kind of fiery around there it's
okay but again it's too identifiable I
like the sense of just this funnel of
energy or time or I don't even know but
and like this is a funnel of clouds I
know what clouds are I know what
lightning is it it's a little bit too
pedestrian the elements it chooses to
give us but it's still a pretty good
version of the composition and it does
work it's just my preferences and
towards those sorts of elements being in
I want something a little weirder than
that number seven the first version of
the tenth doctors opening credits
starting with the Christmas invasion and
that was what 2006 so this one gets
above the Eccleston version and you know
I had another one in between there but
the reason this one's higher is because
they did some nice little things with
the timing that honestly make a big
difference for me which is you know you
had the the the name you know it was
before was Eccleston then it was sending
you the name sort of coming in spinning
and then zooming at the camera it just
kind of did that in the Eccleston one in
the first David Tennant and then
continuing through his entire run they
timed it would the theme a little bit
more so it's going
so it their timing both the turn of the
name and then the zoom at you with what
the theme is doing which is just a much
better way to do it and number six the
tenth doctors second iteration it gets
slightly above the first because they've
redesigned the logo and I like this
version of the logo better otherwise all
the same strengths next up number six
the fourth doctor's original credits
starting with robot in 1974 now this one
has I've always liked the sort of the
effect of the that that tunnel looking
that initially sort of takes the shape
of doctors head and then it takes the
square shape for the logo which was a
really good logo the only thing about
this that I don't care for is it does
sort of start out with the just this
sort of generic more tunnel II looking
thing rather than leading directly in
with with the doctor and the more
identifiable and like fleshed out and
and just more coherent visual bits that
little opening bit brings it down
slightly alright
top five number five the original
opening credits from 1963 with an
unearthly child weird electronic music
weird visuals you don't entirely know
what's going on it really does set the
tone for this show so perfectly and the
only reason I don't have this higher is
I think the tail end of it it just drags
it like it kind of ends but it just
keeps letting the visuals like for like
I don't know five seconds longer than it
needs to and I and one when I'm getting
to this high on on the list it is coming
down to these little tiny differences
but like man that first episode man on
every level
mwah next up the third iteration of the
tenth doctors opening title credits why
is this one higher than the others
because of the composition
[Music]
this has got the big orchestral version
now don't get me wrong I like the
electronic versions I like the sort of
weirdness of the more electronic sound
that we've had at other points but
something about the big orchestra like I
can hear the violins doo doo doo doo doo
doo doo
like I really love this version of the
theme so that on top of the on top of
the previous like refinements that I
already talked about for these credits
that like this this is the best of the
Davey's ever easily I really do like
this number 3 the second doctor's
opening title starting in 1966 first of
all you got that same perfectly tuned
weird electronic sound that actually
stuck around for a while you know they
would later redo the themes like you
really didn't start redoing them until
you got at least not heavily until you
got the fourth doctor so it's stuck with
it for a while and it's got the weird
thing going on and the face I love the
way the face fades in from the visual
noise it's not a complicated effect but
it looks really good and I feel like
it's the perfect expression for the
second doctor cuz it's slightly
off-putting but kind of endearing it's
the absolute opposite of that Tom Baker
one from from his second version of his
opening title where that was the worst
shot they could've think this is the
best shot they could have picked so good
number two the thirteenth doctor's
opening credits
I love these they are so weird that's
visually so strange and it's sort of
like almost organic feels biological but
it is still being reminiscent of the
weird sort of electronic visuals and the
weird ambient look to it while having
this weird other word almost kind of
gooey thing going on at times and the
the orchestration for this version of
the opening theme really intense I love
it this feels so sci-fi this feels like
the heady kind of sci-fi that I want
Doctor Who to do more of and I'm not
gonna say that series 11 lived up to the
promise of these opening titles but god
I like this so much doesn't quite take
the number one spot for me though it was
close it came damn close but ultimately
there's one that just puts the biggest
smile on my face I have no issue with I
think is just perfect the second
iteration of the Third Doctor's opening
credits this started with the time war
in 1973 this was the first iteration of
sort of the blue time tunnel looking
bang because up to that it had just kind
of been you know weird Wibbly just
weirdness now we got something a little
bit different and though again we have
the doctor but he's pulling away from us
and the way he shapes around him and
then the logo comes in it's just perfect
it is a perfect iteration of the show of
this version of the character it is just
weird enough and maybe that's why I put
it above 13th doctor's opening credits
because maybe as much as I love them
maybe those are slightly too weird this
is the perfect level of weird and
everything is pitched just right in
there all these elements that I've knit
picked elsewhere but they're just just
applied perfect for these opening
credits and that's my ranking for the
opening credits of Doctor Who how would
you rank them what are your thoughts on
how I've ranked them whatever your
thoughts are drop something down in the
comments let's talk about it bunch of
stuff to do I mentioned the patreon
because my patrons helped vote and
select this topic as the Doctor Who list
for this month so you can support me on
the patreon help me keep the lights on
and help me cover my bills and also get
to vote in things like that
plus there's other links down there
besides links to my social such as
Instagram see what the heck else I get
up to if you feel like checking that out
a bunch of things subscribe like or
don't you don't have to I'm not gonna
tell you what to do because at the end
of the day you're the council I'm just
running the meetings and until next time
this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]